I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and I have the host of note to self with me.
That's another w n y c podcast that comes out of here. A brilliant one.
And the brilliant tests person who does it all. My news I'm Rodeos is with me.
Hello Robert. And uh,
I asked you to come in just because I wanted you to sort of set this up if you
could.
Oh, happy to.
So we did radio lab and note to self did a joint episode last year called eye in
the sky is a disturbing story,
but I'm like a spy thriller actually. Definitely a spy thriller.
And it turns out a lot has happened since that episode was first put out.
Right? There have been developments which surprise truly surprised me. And uh,
I don't want to give any details,
so just listen to what's about to happen and then don't go away at the end.
Stay. Okay, we'll begin.
So how did you guys find out about this? How'd you get into it?
I think it was somebody was reading about it. Was it,
this is minutia Semarodi or we use you reading about it. Right?
And that's your producer Alex Goldmark and I just said his name is Mick nut and
I just wanted to do a show where I get to say that name at least 10 times
please.
But then like we actually read it and it was weird and interesting and brought
up lots of issues.
[inaudible]
technology is remaking what is possible for individuals and for institutions and
for the international order
[inaudible]
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm a Krulwich Radiolab.
So here we are at this moment in time where we were faced with these decisions
about what we want our future to look like,
be like there are fewer and fewer technical constraints on what we can do.
That place is a special obligation on us to ask tough questions about what
we should have
today.
We're going to look at the can and the should with our friends down the hall.
My new summer roadie and Alex Goldmark,
they run a great podcast called note to self.
They will be our guides into the world of McNutt. Yes.
My name is Ross McNutt. So the McKnight as I refer to him,
he's the next military guy, did 20 years in the air force. I enjoyed it.
I did a lot of good like combat military as an engineer in the middle. Yeah,
I mean I think he's actually special military. My background,
I've got a phd in rapid product development out of MIT and what I do is I teach
young people how to build new systems
[inaudible]
and the new system. That's the system that we want to talk about.
That kind of began in 2007
Ross was teaching a course at a military college,
was that the Air Force Institute of Technology here at Wright Patterson and
Dayton says one day in 2004 the whole school gathered together for a rally and
our commander got up in front of the whole school and said,
we need to do something to help the war effort.
Terrible violence today and the Iraqi city of Basra.
So at that time in the Iraq war for the surge, things were not going well.
Suicide bombs rip through police buildings and city streets [inaudible] going
off
all over the place.
She comes to news about IUD is going off everywhere. Soldiers being blown up.
They, one week I got blown up three times
and to be honest with you, in 2004, it looked like we were going to lose.
So Ross, he gets together some of his students, some of his colleagues,
and they decide, you know, let's sit down and see if we can find a solution.
Quickly find a solution to figuring out who is planting all these roadside
bombs.
Yeah, bombs going off. We're pretty easy to detect in images.
The problem is how do you go from a bomb going off backwards in time to be able
to figure out who planted it. So somehow, uh,
you know, it just came out and it wasn't like you guys sitting around.
It was at a bar.
We were working on the back of the Napkin and we're drawing out different ideas
and throwing them around and seeing what happens. They were just like, hey,
let's use planes. Let's try this. Let's try that. And then they hit on it.
This one stuck. And we sort of drew this out on the back of an envelope making.
It took a little while. I had 38 students working for me for two years,
but eventually they developed what became known as project angel fire.
Here's how it works. Let me take a small plane
and on the belly of the plane, they hook up this array of cameras,
sort of swivel around the camera system. We design and build
super high end and then you're ready to go. The pilot
takes off,
flies the plane high over Fallujah
in the military.
We were up at about 15 to 16,000 feet to stay out of the missile range.
Let's say I'm an Iraqi on the ground in Fallujah and I look up,
what would I see?
You wouldn't see us, you wouldn't hear us or you wouldn't see.
So you've got this plane flying just below the clouds doing an orbit over
Fallujah circle circle,
circle for six hours at a time and every second click,
click, click, click every second.
It takes a still image of the entire city of Felicia 25 square miles and then
beams it down to an operator. We take a picture, process it down, Lincoln,
process it down Lincoln, every single second,
plaintiff's snapping picture after picture after picture.
But here's what makes the system so powerful. The operator on the ground has,
let's say an entire day's worth of these high res pictures of the entire city of
Fallujah. And then let's say there's an explosion.
I'll say at least 20 people were killed in explosions and wounds. 11 others.
First, the operator would pull up the most current image of the city,
zoom into the place within Volusia where it happened, and then click, click,
click in one second increments, go back in time and see who was there,
what happened when was the last time somebody fiddled around in that spot? Yeah.
And you're like, okay, might gone back two hours and ah,
it's that car. Fast forward, click, click, click.
They can now follow that car forward in time to see where it goes.
And you see that it went to a house in another neighborhood two miles away.
Well, that's where you dispatch your troops do, right. Then
basically we'd be able to send either the special forces then or the marines in
and sort of take appropriate action.
[inaudible].
Now look,
the military doesn't release statistics on how well some of it's military
technology works, but there are officers who will be quoted saying that, yes,
project angel fire saved lives.
But the reason why we decided to do this story is because it's not just a
military thing, right? Like with a lot of these technologies,
they may be start in the military,
but then they trickle down all the way down to all of us.
And actually in this case trickled down
[inaudible]
to Dayton, Ohio Ross group incorporated. Do you think that's it?
You a nice first name? Yeah, it'd be weird. Oh,
you gotta go with the producer Andy Mills and I actually went to Dayton,
Ohio to visit Ross at his business.
Persistent surveillance system.
Persistent surveillance systems, right? That feels, or William. Yep.
These are the lenses and the motors here basically control it.
And so first we went over to his workshop where he actually works and makes the
cameras. These are more powerful than some of the best military systems.
Like we could see him actually making them and how they get attached to the
bottoms of the airplane. Oh, so many
airplanes. Then we went over to the hangar where he has all the airplanes.
Beautiful. Overall we've got 27 airplanes. We operate.
He owns his own airport. Yeah. Yeah. After you guys. Oh my God.
It's big.
And then he showed us their command center and this is where you have a bunch of
people sitting in front of these enormous screens.
This is like your viewing room. Yeah,
and this is where all the plane pictures end up
because Ross's basic idea in taking this technology from Fallujah to a city like
Dayton, Ohio is basically this
u us cities has just as large a problem as we do in Afghanistan and Iraq only
it's not IED is it's crying.
We've had a lot of major events this year.
We've had four officer involved shootings so far this year.
Our homicides are up this year. So this is Dayton police chief, Richard BLB, I.
E. H. L.
I talked to him last summer a couple of years ago.
Ross called him up and was like, look,
a city like Dayton, Ohio, we've got 28,000 crimes a year,
about 10,000 part one crimes, murder, rape, assault,
10,000 part one crimes comes out to be $480 million a year.
But McKnight is like for the bout the price of a police helicopter,
we believe that we would be able to decrease crime by 30 to 40%. 30%
decrease in that is $155 million a year.
The Dayton police were like, Alrighty, let's give it a shot.
We basically set up a test in June of 2012 for a five day flight.
Here we go. Let's see for ourselves what it was capable of doing
isn't sent the plane up in the air,
started doing its thing just like in Fallujah. And within just a few hours,
oh, there was a call of this, uh, breaking,
entering and progress with a description of a van.
Um, it was an older white box truck, just a regular random moving truck.
This is Angie Horn. She's the one who called nine one one.
She was just home on her lunch break and she sees a moving van pull up in front
of her neighbor's house. The guy gets out, breaks in,
starts moving furniture out.
No, we, you know, we immediately called the police.
They got there relatively quickly from what I remember,
that he had already taken off.
Yeah. Normally in a case like this, the police would be like, well,
how do we follow them? We don't know where he went, but in this case,
the police contact persistent surveillance systems and ultimately they get
connected to this guy. My name is Alex [inaudible].
I'm the senior analyst for the company.
Alex pulls up the image of gene zooms in cliques backwards.
Did about five minutes until he sees this little grainy white dot appear in
front of her neighbor's house. This is the vehicle here that we're wanting to,
I'm sorry, what vehicle? I don't, I barely see anything. Right.
So the image looks real blurry, but the human brain and the human eyes are very,
very evolved to pick out movement.
You got to understand that from two miles up a car looks just like a random
shape and people, they look like pixels.
Alex has trained himself to pick out movement.
I'm going to put a tag down on where he's at,
places in orange circle over that random little shape and then click
[inaudible].
He moves forward, forward, forward to follow him to his real time location.
Alex follows it up. Some roads finds out that it is parked in a parking lot.
Six blocks away. He calls up, the people in the field goes,
go over there. They get there. They see the guy, they see a truck full of stuff.
They send one different cop over to pick up. The witness. Witness goes. Yep,
that's the guy. Oh, so this lady who called, yeah, this is minutes later.
No kidding.
That could have been a murderer. Right? That could've been an armed robber.
It could have been a lot of things.
This is so weird because like having a superpower,
it is actually better than Batman.
You can't go back forth in time if you're a superhero.
I just feel sad.
All right. It's like we're all just these little dots.
It just seems like the antithesis of what a lot of police departments seem to be
trying to do in the aftermath of Ferguson and Staten Island and other, um,
horrific things that have happened,
which is getting the police on the streets,
making personal connections, creating relationship. There's
nothing in this system that prevents you from having effective community
policing at the same time. And Oh, by the way,
this may dramatically help that community relations,
the reason they're putting body cams on police officers is try to get the police
officers to be more respectful because they can be seen while this lets us watch
all the officers in a 25 square mile area all at once,
but then you can watch so many other people all at once.
Here's the other things that people in Dayton do, like Romeo and Juliet,
they sometimes meet without their parents' permission in the playground and
smooch.
There are going to be divorced lawyers who are going to be tracking Aaron
spouses. There are going to be traffic police who are watching,
who goes through the red light.
They're going to be realtors who are wondering who are,
how many tenants do you really have in that building?
And I guess the thought might be that if the information exists that will show
what my pixel was actually doing then then I'm a little less
free. There is a clear trade off between security and privacy.
And you know, in our major cities where we have, you know,
tens of thousands of major crimes,
you are a lot less free when you can't leave your house at night.
There's obviously a and a huge advantage to knowing what you know.
But then there's a huge thing to knowing what you know,
like knowledge all by itself is sort of uh, is pregnant with, with
funny do you know, here's my problem with, with the, with this,
with all of these privacy stories,
it's like when you're talking about these technologies,
the advantages are always so concrete and the tradeoffs always feel so abstract.
I feel like there is this, there's something being lost here,
but I can never quite put my finger on it. It's weird. Oh,
Jab that weirdness that you're feeling. Yes, it's going to get a lot weirder.
We'll be right back.
[inaudible]
Hey, this is Jenny lan hand from round lake, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation in the Lansing
public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by New York life.
New York life knows that when your finances are under control,
you're free to think about important stuff like a new house or Ukulele lesson or
whatever New York life can help you get there.
Did you know that New York life is a mutual life insurer?
That means they answer to policy owners,
not Wall Street as part of the New York life family. That means you. Cool story.
So start a plan today and find out more about beingGood@lifeatnewyorklife.com
hi, this is Mckenna Anderson at the University of South Florida.
Currently in the woman's laboratory,
Radiolab is supported by Poopourri the before you go toilet spray.
The good folks at Poopourri once reminded that using the restroom for 10 minutes
each day at work equals 40 hours a year. Hey,
that's like an extra week of vacation.
So is it [inaudible] dot com to find out how you can go anywhere with confidence
even at work into the discount code.
Where do you elab for 20% off@potpourri.com. See Ya.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember Krill, which is radio lab and uh,
we'll continue our collaboration with the Minutia Moroni and Alex Goldmark from
note to self and our subject is and remains eyes in the sky in the situation
when we left it as it minutia, one of our producers, Andy Mills,
had gone down to Dayton, Ohio to talk with Ross McNutt,
check out his technology and a after the date and demo. What were you,
how were you feeling about things? Well, I was feeling like, ah,
you have not convinced me. I do. I am not going for this.
And then I saw war as Mexico and that, well,
I mean that's what made me start to think otherwise.
Whereas a, especially at the time we did this,
they averaged 300 murders a month and 52 kidnappings a week.
300 murders a month. Yeah. McNaughton the gang,
they got a contract we'd been asked not to say for whom and they went down
south, set themselves up in a hotel room,
got the plane up in the sky and then whoever the client was started bringing
them prime reports. So this is kind of what you never want to see happen.
But uh, this is kind of why the system was up. Alex pulls up on the screen,
this very grainy aerial shot of war as this is, whereas Mexico,
it looks like any city, right?
You've got like grids of streets and cars and houses and then like over on the
left of the screen, he points to this dark little square.
It's a vehicle that's going down the street. This is a female police officer.
She was actually headed to work, uh, on this morning.
Uh, so we'll kind of go through it here.
He starts at the beginning and you see there's her house and her car is parked
outside.
You see that like teeny little pixel gets in her car and she pulls out of her
driveway. That was her home starts to drive to work. Um,
and then right when she leaves, uh,
if you look up here, he points to the upper left of the screen. Um,
several cars were parked up on the corner. As soon as she left her driveway,
those cars become active.
So this is a stakeout. Yeah, they were waiting for her to leave.
He's so zoomed in that you can see,
it's like a ticktack moving down the street.
And then two more tictacs come alongside until they get right about here.
He's clicking forward on the photo and you see there is a speed bump.
These cars just inch closer social kind of hesitate there, which is unfortunate.
Um,
so she's driving down the street and there's these cars following behind her and
then there's this car up ahead of her.
A vehicle that had been parked here for 15, 20, 30 minutes,
all of a sudden backs out into traffic and seemingly slows them down,
almost gets in an accident right here. Um,
which gives these guys enough time, uh, to catch up.
This is where they're gonna pull up beside her
and then suddenly,
oh,
um, Alex says right there. This is the point.
[inaudible]
where here the first car pulls up and shoots her multiple times.
She was shot in the head multiple times in the head right here.
[inaudible]
she's actually gonna roll through the intersection. Her car continues to go,
even though she's been shot in the head.
There is a parked car behind this tree and you'll actually see this parked car
move when she runs into it.
And then these guys take off.
[inaudible]
yeah, it was not fun to watch.
It was upsetting.
But what happens next made me really start to understand what this technology is
capable of real quickly. Just show you some of the other bras walks in.
He takes that moment, horrible moment.
And then he starts to like shoot back and forth in time. Suspect car, one years,
his bath before the murder. Here's his path. After the murder,
he actually takes the too cars from that murder.
And you see he draws on the map.
You see that they meet up with two other cars that were involved in a different
murder. Now one murder becomes two, two cars become four car stops.
And if you follow all four of these cars,
drawing lines as they move through the city,
you find out who they meet up with them. Four becomes eight,
eight becomes 16 so on and so on. And you have all these lines,
criss crossing the city.
And then you see that all whole bunch of those cars are headed to one place.
This house, this house appears to be their cartel headquarters.
And that's when you start to think, okay,
well that's how you have to take something like this down.
It's not a one shot thing like solving the crime.
It's about cracking an entire system.
In fact, um, this is Andy here,
but when I was doing some research into this,
I made a bunch of calls and I spoke with this one governmental source who told
me that this information, that Rasa just showed us,
like it was one of the primary tools used to dismantle an entire cartel in wars,
and that apparently the leader, that cartel
was responsible for something like 1500 murders.
Whoa. So I got asked again. So how are you feeling at this point?
Are you happy or scared or of the same of myself because I thought,
oh,
the reason why I'm so excited about it is it because it's in a country where I
don't live and I'm an outsider and I think of it as being messed up.
So it's okay for them, but it's still not okay for us.
What did you think Andy? I mean
like this is where I stopped being a good journalist because I picked aside,
it feels wrong to not solve these crimes that we can solve it.
What if this plan is on top of New York? Good God, really?
For me it became low.
But do you remember like after nine 11 when you'd walk down the street and you'd
hear the [inaudible] circling over the city?
And I just remember the feeling in my stomach was like nausea.
Like I felt sick. It felt gross.
It felt like we had no autonomy over ourselves.
And at that point I was scared enough that I could live with it.
But right now I don't feel that way. And look,
it's a very privileged position to be able to say that we shouldn't have it.
I get that. And that's what I'm saying,
like I became a convert because somebody got kidnapped today and if we had an
eye in the sky,
we might be able to get the kid back in a few minutes hours compared to like,
you see the stats on on amber alerts, they're not good yet.
But what we're talking about is like,
and I'm not saying that I'm like anti McNutt at all,
but what I'm saying is like,
it's very easy to paint it as we're going to get bad guys.
And I just don't think it's that simple. The McNaughton Co,
they seem like decent people. They have set limitations for themselves.
They have said they will not use photography that could get any closer.
They've made a moral choice with that.
How do we know other people will make the same moral choice and that even though
this thing might solve a ton of crimes, might save lives.
It's still not worth the risk because it just asks a level of trust in
government that we shouldn't, we shouldn't give. Is that what you're saying
for now? Yes. So back to Dayton. What happened in Dayton? Well,
I was pretty impressed. I was pretty impressed. After that five day demo,
the police chief, Richard Beale,
I recommended that we enter into a contract with persistence surveillance
systems and so they took it to the city commission.
Carrie Gregg. Oh Hey Carrie. It's minutia New York.
And according to Carrie Gray,
director of the city commission office for the city of Dayton,
Ohio committee saw the presentation and they liked it.
The city commission was interested in, in the presentation,
but they decided that before they go forward, they should have a public forum.
So they could just, you know, sort of hear from the people.
There was about 75 or so people there and he says that the people of Dayton,
like much like the people of Radiolab and note to self, we're very divided.
A quarter of the people were supportive of this technology and they were
frustrated with the amount of crime. Their belief was,
I'm not doing anything wrong so I don't care what people see me doing.
We want this implemented and we want to implement it very broadly.
So a quarter of them were like, you know, bring it on.
They were basically in the Indy camp woo. But then there was another group,
slightly smaller, but now my much,
maybe 15% that was the Robert Minutia camp who believed that this was a
grotesque invasion of privacy.
And some of the people spoke in very impassioned terms.
So yay.
I think calling it grotesque invasion of privacy would pretty much reflect the
weight that way. This group was feeling this group too,
and that there was no way that you could trust government with this volume of
information and this breadth of information. So you had your pros and cons.
The rest of the people liked the majority,
maybe had some feelings one way or another,
but just didn't have enough information.
And so they came and kind of asked questions like how long will persist in
surveillance systems keep the images 90 days, how far can they zoom in?
Can they see my face? No. So they had a lot of questions,
which Carrie seems to think that they could've answered.
They could've gotten everybody on board, but in the end,
even though the room was basically divided into three parts,
the naysayers were so loud and so impassioned that they sort of defined the
conversation as we do.
So we took that lesson to understand that there was going to be some significant
education that was gonna be needed and some significant hurdles that we're going
to have to be crossed.
Before that we were able to do a broad based implementation and based on the
amount of time that was going to have to be spent,
we decided there were other more immediate techniques it could be used that
could be invested in and we took the money that could've been spent on this and
spend it on some other activities.
Because it seems like what you're saying is that like it was just going to be
too hard to get people over the hurdle, so like, Eh, it's not worth it. Yeah,
I think that's probably pro probably accurate. Um,
so the plane is off the table so to speak. It's off the table for right now.
[inaudible]
but that doesn't mean that it's never coming back on the table.
which I think is fair to say is a frustrating to him.
Right now we've got about $150 million with a proposal sitting out there for a
large number of cities, Baltimore, Philadelphia, the Moscow,
we've been the Lunder. We're waiting for them to make decisions.
We've done Compton and roles.
Compton's like maybe or as is like maybe Dayton is like maybe
it's a whole lot of babies out there.
And what McKnight and his team were doing now,
and this is actually what they were doing when we went to visit them, they're
analyzing
what we're doing here in Dayton is we are looking at a
turn pike or something traffic in New Jersey. They're studying traffic problems.
We look at congested areas, which are typically,
especially in that part of the country,
exits a in onramps any kind of junction in a highway.
Sometimes you just want to scream
[inaudible]
since we did that story, things have happened. Minutia did they have.
And so I've invited you back here to fill us in on further developments of which
there have been gigantic ones very recently.
Yes. And McNutt says not just since we heard that episode,
but because we aired that episode. Uh,
well after this episode first went out,
it turns out that there were a couple very wealthy philanthropists listening to
radio lab and they picked up the phone. They called him and they said,
we would like to be the people that bank roll you giving us a try in a,
in an American city somewhere.
So they, he, they just said, we'll write you a check if you can land the city,
we'll give you the money.
Pretty much we just look at who are these people?
They are Laura and John Arnold. They're young, they're in their early forties.
They're in Texas. And by the time that they contacted McNutt,
he had already done as, as we said,
he'd already done a very extensive look at cities across the nation looking for
the one that had the biggest crime issue. And as he puts it,
the strongest political leadership,
somebody who would be willing to put up with the firestorm that would inevitably
ensue. Um, Baltimore fit the bill.
It had a mayor who said she was very tough on crime shootings were actually up
in Baltimore by 72% last year.
So he went back to Baltimore and said, if I can get the money for this,
are you game? And they were like, sure.
So the rich folks were willing to give money to the mayor of Baltimore to put a
plane in the sky to take pictures of Baltimore for a discrete period.
No, not quite.
So it didn't go to the government or any elected officials.
Nobody needed to sign off on this in the city of Baltimore other than the police
commissioner,
which is why he was able to do it without telling any of the city council
members or, uh, the mayor.
The second way is Baltimore's police department without telling the mayor or the
city council or anybody decides to contract with this fellow supported by two
people in Texas to put a plane in the sky to gaze down at Baltimore and
everybody in Baltimore and they just don't mention this to the mayor.
Did McNaughton move to Baltimore and
Oh yeah, he moved to Baltimore. Um, and they set up a,
across the street from the police station and had the,
bout a dozen analysts sitting there for two months looking at everything that
was going on in Baltimore.
So they did see some stuff during this period. Like, give me a, an,
an example like of something bad that happened that they did.
Here's one that we know about, which is that there was an elderly, um,
brother and sister. The woman is 90 years old. Uh,
the brother is 82 and they were cross,
they were near this bus stop and they actually got in the line of fire.
They got gunned down by a shooter. Um,
and so they ended up tracking a couple cars,
but then later they think the police say, actually we think he got away on foot.
I think it was a witness on the ground who said that they thought that he had
left on foot. Oh and so rewind.
And they see a dot scrambling to get away from the scene.
It goes down the street, it passes the subway sandwich shop.
It goes between these two houses.
I'm stops at a car that's parked and then it ends up at,
they later discovered the home of a woman and turns out her boyfriend is
somebody who has a long criminal record. Um,
and so there are over 700 CCTV cameras on the streets in Baltimore.
And so the idea is that it's sort of a support mechanism, right?
Like they get the high level, then it goes to the street.
Then you've got the officers on the [inaudible],
right? Yeah.
So if the shooter shoots and then gets into a car and goes down elm street,
you have cameras down on Elm Street and you can see maybe the car and then the
driver's license and maybe even capture the face. Exactly.
And did they eventually arrest this person?
So he crossed state lines and the feds picked him up. Okay.
So they've made the arrest,
they go into court and they say to the judge or Kay,
we obtain information about this suspect in part through a spire plan.
Does the stuff that they gathered during this few months,
is that now going before judges and becoming evidenced and arrests and
prosecutions?
Well, not yet. We talked to the state's attorney's office.
They got a briefing about a month ago from the police about what [inaudible] had
been up to.
And they also told us that there are five open and pending cases where this
surveillance technology was used. Police are using it.
And they say this is the state's attorney's office,
that they're looking forward to learning more about what McNutt actually does
and that they are trying to determine whether in fact all those pictures could
be used in some way at trial, but they're not ready to say yes,
this absolutely will pass legal muster in a trial. It God,
this is a the other objection that I guess I was thinking about,
was it the defense,
the people as a matter of justice as a matter of the fourth amendment? Well,
you know, this is going to come up at some point. Yeah.
Then the defense lawyers would say, wait a second. Um,
this evidence against my client was obtained without not only his or her
permission,
but without anybody's permission and the entire town is now in effect,
searchable during, yes. On sunny days.
And did the founding fathers want that to happen?
To be honest, the,
the supreme court hasn't seen a ton of these master valence cases, but actually,
Robert, I mean,
I happened to have the fourth amendment here and I want to read it to you.
It's got, it says you can't do the searches and seizures are prohibit.
Yeah. The right of the people to be secure in their persons houses,
papers and effects against unreasonable searches and seizures shall not be
violated and no warrants shall issue but upon probable cause supported by oath
or affirmation and particularly describing the place to be searched and the
persons or things to be seized.
So by that token you could say people to be searched, everyone in Baltimore,
places to be looked at every place in Baltimore,
oath to be a obtained ahead of time blanket.
That's a pretty radical thing.
Yeah, and when you put it like that, no wonder there is very likely to be a,
an inevitable big legal public debate over whether this is the answer to
Baltimore's crime problem. McNutt says he thinks very,
very soon the police are going to release an evaluation report looking at the
effectiveness of his planes.
He thinks that whatever Baltimore decides,
that's going to set a precedent for midsize cities that are struggling across
the United States.
I'm Robert Krulwich and I'm a new summer OT. From note to self,
you can go to radio lab.org for more information about the making.
Right? And also, please,
I hope you'll check out note to self radio.org special thanks to Alex Goldmark
also to Dan Tucker and George Scholz. By the way,
the piece that we just listened to was produced by Andy Mills. Uh,
he has produced a any number of Radiolab stories over the years,
and he has decided to move to the New York Times.
He's been a tremendous boon to us over and over again.
He's brought a worldview and a sensibility that we didn't have before.
He came, not really, and now he's going to work for that obscure newspaper,
but nevertheless, we wish him all the best.
And thank you Andy so much. And thanks. Of course.